this video is sponsored by surf shark
vpn
use the link in the description for 83
off and three months for free
laid on her bed horizontally her chin
propped up on one of her pillows
rebecca watched her fish swim around its
tank moving from the right side to the
left side
pausing there for a moment then from the
left to the right pausing there for a
moment
and then back over and over as it
usually did
while watching her fish whom she had
named shiny rebecca talked about her day
and whatever else was on her mind as she
usually did
rebecca was a very intelligent young
child and perhaps somewhat related to
this
she was also quite a lonely isolated
child
she had bad social anxiety as a
consequence of her genetics
her tendency to overthink and a set of
parents who also suffered from various
social anxieties
surrounding rebecca with a constant
unsettling tension
during her formative years as a result
rebecca often had a difficult time
communicating especially with kids her
own age and struggled to make many
friends during this early part of her
life
in a sort of way at this time her best
friend was her fish
some of the greatest conversations she
ever had were with shiny
she would tell it everything unhindered
and unencumbered
she would complain to shiny about her
parents and teachers she would tell it
what she was sad about when she was sad
what she was happy about when she was
happy what she wanted to do and who she
wanted to be when she was older
and so on all the while shiny swam its
few routes back and forth
every once in a while stopping and
staring with its naive unaware eyes
back in her direction still at an
inevitably naive age
rebecca felt the inclination to believe
that in these moments
shiny sort of understood and personally
loved her like a friend
although it's possible that shinee did
at some point start to recognize the
recurring patterns of rebecca's facial
arrangement
and associate her likeness with food it
of course
did not actually like nor no rebecca in
any real sense of these terms at all
it was a fish it hadn't the slightest
clue as to how to form the slightest
clue
of what or in this case who rebecca was
its mental framework far too small its
perceptual and cognitive capacity
essentially null shinee would go on to
live 15
healthy years aging with rebecca through
her adolescence
sort of out of habit rebecca continued
to talk with shinee throughout the rest
of its life
of course rebecca would soon realize how
foolish it was to be talking with her
fish
understanding that shinee almost
certainly did not get her or
like her on any level at all but
nonetheless she still enjoyed the
routine
now though on the occasions when shiny's
eyes looked back at her
rebecca found herself wondering instead
that if not really her
what exactly was shiny experiencing
could it recognize her in any form at
all
could it understand her at all did it
really process anything as the reality
that was actually happening
rebecca reflected on the fact that
shinee obviously knew she was some sort
of something
that was happening around or to it
whenever she did something like
feed it or put her hand into the tank
and so forth
but yet at the same time since shiny did
not and could not know
what that something actually was and why
it was doing what it was doing
rebecca's image and touch and vocal
vibrations
were things happening to it with no
conscious source
there was no way for it to understand
that rebecca was a living human being
that loved it that cared for it that
those sound waves she emitted
had meaning contained inside them that
there even were sound waves at all
that there was specific thoughtful
conscious intention in the movements
around
and towards it although shiny could
never know it had a huge impact on
rebecca's life
their sort of relationship greatly
influencing her as she asked these sorts
of questions
learning more about herself and her
interests of the world
between the bond she formed with shiny
her social anxiety
and her hard time communicating over the
course of her early teens
rebecca became deeply interested in the
ways in which species develop
and carry out language delving further
into this research field
known as linguistics
in high school rebecca created and ran
her school's first linguistics club
took multiple summer linguistic courses
hosted by local universities
and explored deeper and deeper into her
own research
in college she worked for several
linguistic and cognitive science
research groups
was an assistant for the school's
leading anthropological linguistics
professor
and already began concluding her senior
thesis by this time
garnering serious interest and respect
from this professor as well as other
faculty
by age 22 rebecca received her phd
and by her early 30s she had become a
leading linguist
teaching as a professor at uc berkeley
writing several majorly successful books
winning numerous awards and becoming
internationally recognized for her work
in language acquisition
and psycholinguistics
at age 45 however in her species year of
rebecca's career would dramatically
shift inverting her in a totally
different direction
earlier the same year a strange radio
signal was intercepted by a telescope
that was used as part of a university
program that scanned deep space
searching for signs of extraterrestrial
intelligent life
this was the first time in human history
that an observed space signal
showed sufficient power suitably narrow
bandwidth
and a range of small radio frequencies
that added up to indicate an artificial
nature to the signal
upon examination it was believed to be a
highly likely candidate
for extraterrestrial life as a result of
this groundbreaking moment
efforts to decipher and analyze the
signal develop the search for subsequent
signals
and transmit corresponding signals back
into space
all increased as a part of this growing
initiative
rebecca was sought out and recruited by
an organization
known as the international contact group
for extraterrestrial intelligence
the hope being to utilize her leading
knowledge of language acquisition
and language types for the purposes of
both interpreting and broadcasting
messages to and from
alternate types of beings rebecca
couldn't turn down such an unusual and
interesting opportunity
and so after a little negotiating she
took the job
years and years would go by rebecca
would become a key member of the
organization
leading a specific team that worked on
developing and broadcasting various
sorts of signals into deep space
signals that could theoretically be
picked up by another species within 100
plus million light years away
additionally they developed and sent out
space probes housing various plaques
audio and video recordings music
mathematics
and other forms of information and
communication despite these great
efforts though
no explanation would ever conclusively
be found for the initial signal
and no more of its kind would ever seem
to reappear
throughout this later portion of her
career rebecca couldn't help but wonder
more and more
where everybody was in a potentially
endless space
with billions and billions of years
behind humanity how is there no one else
out there
almost every night rebecca spent some
time on her porch
looking up into the stars entirely
perplexed by the strange paradox
that her work seemed to illuminate and
reinforce
that somehow it is likely that at least
several hundred million
if not several billion earth-sized
planets were out there
with inhabitable conditions for life in
just the milky way galaxy alone
and potentially trillions of habitable
planets in the universe at large
and if human development and technology
were to be extrapolated
to any reasonable degree in relation to
the size and age of the universe
even if just a small percentage of these
planets had formed life
the galaxy should be rife with signs of
it by now but yet
the universe appeared dead and quiet
humanity
alone the great silence
right now rebecca continues on moving
around her planet
mostly back and forth between two
sections work and home
pausing and hovering in one for a little
then to the other
hovering there for a little and then
back again over and over
as she usually does right now as it
usually does
a being from the species known as what
loosely translates into
[Music]
named what loosely translates into
or just 011l for short hovers outside
or sort of in between time and space
watching rebecca
talking to her about whatever is on its
mind
011l is a member of a super-intelligent
species who
a long long time ago evolved from one of
the earliest lineages of life
that formed and survived the early
budding universe
as it successfully evolved through time
it developed intelligence
built technology extended out past its
host planet
harnessed the power of its host star
eventually breaching the bonds of
biological and neurobiological
conditions
building and collectivizing with other
galactic life forms
and finally harnessing the total energy
of its host galaxy
over time the superintelligent species
had gotten smaller and smaller
moving further up the interdimensional
rungs of physical reality
until it became what would appear
immaterial to all beings of other
dimensional levels
now the species traverses the universe
exploring and perceiving things
outside and in between time not confined
to it
nor the same physical material and
conditions that can find
one two three four five six seven
eight and nine dimensional space
rebecca's reality is accessible to o11l
in a way that might be sort of similar
to the way in which rebecca accesses
information
from an external computer hard drive
displaying the stored information bits
onto a separate monitor screen
accessible to species with the
technology to locate extract
and read it her reality's information is
contained in bits of information
stored on the outer edge of the
universe's geometric surface
which can then be observed through a
sort of hologram like projection
although this is metaphorically sound in
truth trying to accurately explain and
understand such a phenomenon
with these words through such a human
mode of thinking would sort of be like
rebecca
trying to explain physics to her fish
specifically 011l is an especially
intelligent
super intelligent being perhaps somewhat
related to this
it is also a particularly lonely and
isolated super intelligent being
it has a bad form of what could sort of
be the equivalent to social anxiety
as a consequence of its tendency to
overthink and some portion of its
maladaptive input codes
consequently it often has a difficult
time communicating with others
especially its own kind it has and
continues to struggle to make many
friends
and in a sort of way at this time
rebecca
is its best friend some of the greatest
conversations it has ever had were with
rebecca
it tells her everything unhindered and
unencumbered
it complains to her it tells her about
its life about what it's like to be
alone and to exist in the condition that
it does
what its favorite and least favorite
things are its favorite places in the
universe
and so on early on when 011l
by chance picked out rebecca not too
dissimilar from the way in which rebecca
picked out shinee
it initially thought that she sort of
understood and loved it like a friend
that when she stopped and looked up into
the stars with her naive unaware eyes
pointed in its direction
she knew 011l but of course it didn't
take long for 011l to realize
that there was no way for rebecca to
understand and know of it at all
she was a human she hadn't the slightest
clue as to how to form the slightest
clue
of what or in this case who 011l was
she couldn't know that it loved her that
it cared for her that the
interdimensional frequencies it emitted
had meaning contained inside them
that there even were any frequencies at
all that there could be intention in the
universe's motion
around her rebecca could visually see
and feel the oscillations of motion and
physical material that were the
consequences of o11l's thoughts and
actions
manifesting at the quantum level in what
appeared to be random particle behavior
but she could not know nor attribute any
thoughts or concepts to this
to rebecca and the rest of humanity
there was no real source
her mental framework far too small her
perceptual and cognitive capacity
essentially null in comparison
ironically 011l and the rest of its
species never knew that rebecca and her
human colleagues had been trying to
contact them
or anyone the physical objects sent out
look like meaningless debris
and the radio signals on the few
occasions that they actually reached
them
appeared to be but a primitive foreign
noise that translated into nothing for
them
at times some did consider the
possibility that the radio broadcasts
were some form of an effort
to communicate with them but just like
how rebecca did not seriously bark back
at a dog
when it was barking at her to
communicate this species never thought
to
nor knew how to properly bark back
except for the one time
in 1977 when they tried in a kind of
humorous playful effort
which ultimately served no purpose
in truth there was in fact a galaxy rife
with technology and signs of other life
rebecca and the rest of her species were
right in this conclusion
but wrong when they assumed that they
would recognize it
and so continuing to this day they still
think
they're alone like most species like
them
they don't see anything and so they
assume nothing is there
but just like rebecca was right there in
the room was shiny but shiny had no way
of knowing that the physical shape of
her
was an intelligent being named rebecca
right there in the room with rebecca
was 0-1 l but rebecca had no way of
knowing
that the emergent physical phenomena of
it was a super intelligent being
named 011l
[Music]
this video was sponsored by surfsharkvpn
with various potential threats to your
data and information
lurking on the internet staying safe and
secure on your devices
is of course a very important practice
surfshark is a vpn service
that makes this fast easy and affordable
by hiding your ip address
encrypting your data and scanning for
email compromises
surfshark guards and conceals your
identity location
passwords photos and other personal
information
from any sort of online risk in addition
to protecting your data and personal
information
surfshark also provides a ton of great
practical features
to further increase your overall web
browsing experience in general
for example by letting you change your
device's location
surfshark allows you to bypass various
country restrictions and censorships
and thus access any and all internet
content
no matter where you're physically at in
the world additionally it also allows
you to access different offerings and
formats from website platforms
that can vary based on user geography
like for example
the 15 different libraries of netflix or
the lower prices for things like airfare
car rentals
and other e-commerce products that can
often be affected and targeted
differently
in different countries with just one
subscription
surfshark can be used on as many devices
as you'd like at the same time
meaning all your personal devices as
well as your friends and families
if you're interested you can get
surfsharkvpn for 83
off the regular price plus three months
for free by clicking the link in the
description below
or by going to surfshark.deals pow
and using the promo code pow and of
course
thank you so much for watching in
general and see you next video
[Music]
you